mais permettez moi comme d'innombrables
français ce matin d'avoir des doutes
parce que je crains que tout cela ne
ressemble à une farce dont les français
ne seraient que les dindons parce que la
question n'est pas de savoir qui est ou
tel ou tel ministre tel ou tel premier
ministre la question c'est qui est
président de la république et le prison
la république s'appelle emmanuel macron
et son bilan hélas al'inverse des
promesses qui nous présente depuis
quelques jours ou quelques semaines est
très abîmée 1000 milliards d'euros
d'impôts 2700 milliards d'euros de dette
un record d'immigration 276000 titre de
séjour qui ont été accordés tout cela ne
plaide pas en la faveur d' emmanuel
macron et le rôle nous avec l'est
républicain christian jacob et
l'ensemble de notre famille politique
c'est de rester une position
constructive
si la politique se résume à du spectacle
à du cynisme à de la simple tactique et
à des stratégies de débauchage
individuel
qu'est ce qu'elle est triste la
politique et c'est celle que mène
emmanuel macron bien sûr vous avez
raison qu'il tente pour amuser la
galerie pour se regarder le nombril
plutôt que de s'occuper de nos
compatriotes pour nous permettre ce
matin j'espère qu'on dépassera pas trop
de temps de commenter ce qu'il fait il
tente cela mais la noble politique c'est
d'apporter des réponses fortes
courageuse et concrètes à nos
compatriotes qui doute et qui souffre
mois en cet instant je pense aux
ouvriers aux employés aux agriculteurs
aux entrepreneurs aux chômeurs aux
fonctionnaires à tout retraité à toutes
celles et ceux qui s'inquiètent de la
crise économique et sociale que nous
vivons et qui attendent du nouveau
gouvernement des mesures claires
emmanuel macron a terriblement abîmé le
lien de confiance entre les français et
nos forces de l'ordre et surtout entre
le gouvernement et les forces de l'ordre
nos policiers dont gendarmes sont des
hommes et des femmes qui est tout le
temps au péril de leur vie et parfois
même au sacrifice ultime de leur vie
nous protège de la délinquance du grand
banditisme du terrorisme on a besoin de
nos forces de l'ordre il faut donc des
des messages très forts d'apaisement
premièrement il faut des moyens et il
faudra que gérald armes
il sera jugé là-dessus rétablissent
l'ordre dans les banlieues lutte contre
les incivilités et mène une grande
politique acharnée d'éradication du
communautarisme
parce que chacun sait aujourd'hui en
france que dans notre pays hélas la
halle à la fois de quelques-uns a
tendance à l'emporter sur la loi la
république doit protéger la foi de tous
mais doit rappeler qu'au dessus de la
fois il y à la loi qui s'applique à
chacun partout et pour tous aujourd'hui
en france ce que nous disent nos
compatriotes ce que nous disent aussi
les policiers et gendarmes qui font leur
travail c'est que les travaux
d'interpellations et d' enquêtes sont
plutôt bien réalisé mais qu'à l'issue de
deux sets de ces étapes systématiquement
trop souvent les délinquants sont
relâchés et impunies et bien pour que la
justice revienne juste il faut que le
ministre garde des sceaux dupond-moretti
l'incarnent avec force avec autorité et
avec impartialité la justice doit être
rétablie notre de notre pays elle macron
qui est au pouvoir depuis désormais
trois ans à ce billet à ce bilan
terrible d'une part il lui reste 18 mois
pour recoudre notre pays qui est
profondément fragmentée divisé et c'est
sur les actes et les résultats que nous
le jugerons
moi vous savez je préfère alors c'est
peut-être démodé mais j'en suis fier je
préfère les convictions la carrière
emmanuel macron incarne exactement ce
que je viens de développer et ce en quoi
je crois alors comme j'aime mon pays
j'espère qu'avec ce nouveau gouvernement
ça va changer je voudrais bien vous avez
bien compris que j'ai des doutes sérieux
donc il n'est pas question de servir un
président de la république pour ma part
qui depuis trois ans fragmente divise
notre patrie ça compte vous savez mais
vous ne les convictions mais